but I think I think I picked my battles
better now than I used to I may I could
use you know I could turn any dinner
party into a you know a knock down drag
out debate about the most fundamental
issues
uh anyone could summon and you know I
think I
um as I get older I pick my battles more
um just because I like that the hassle
factor of touching certain topics in
certain ways has has become more Salient
for me because I the Twitter was that
was the real teaching tool for me like I
I just you know I got on the platform as
everyone did not really aware that I was
enrolling myself into a psychological
experiment to which no one had consented
and and the the outcome is as yet
unforeseen and
um yeah I just kind of let loose you
know with it on various topics and I
would you know when I would see some
malefactor there who was treating me or
other people badly well then I had to
deal with that right then and there and
and
um
yeah it's just uh the hassle factor of
dealing with the the toxicity of it and
also just the
the um
I'm convinced now that at the bottom
it's a misrepresentation of humanity
right it doesn't seem like I mean you're
actually dealing with what someone wrote
there I mean it's not it's not in error
but you're not getting the whole person
you're getting a a um
uh a part of them that has been
Amplified by the the frame into which
the conversation has been put and the
the frame has certain features that are
not helpful to good conversation I mean
it's got anonymity it's got you know
it's got facelessness it's got
um the performative aspect you're doing
it in front of your crowd or some
possible crowd so it just it you know
it's disastrous for intellectual honesty
and and
um compassion and
uh
you know theory of Mind under actually
understand taking the time the extra
moment to understand where the other
person is coming from and so it's either
there's no principle of Charity so it's
just it's really a disastrous machine
for uh manufacturing Discord
we had a guest on the show called
Richard Grant who made the point that
what it does is reduces everyone to an
avatar so if everyone's an avatar what
does it matter if you attack them if you
you know dehumanize them if you
misrepresent them because the game is to
win right it's not to actually have a
discussion is to destroy and ultimately
to win
yeah well especially if you're not if
you're a public person dealing with
people who are not public people right
because then there's really this then
it's just a single shot you know Lottery
it's not a there's no
ongoing future of collaboration or
cooperation that is is being maintained
I mean it's even bad when you have two
public people who you know are who know
both know they're gonna
meet each other in real life at some
point still the the wheels come off
rather often uh to a surprising degree
but
um
yeah it's just uh
yes I in the end I think it's bad
technology which is it's still somewhat
inscrutable because it seems like it
should be good I mean and in some ways
it is good because you're seeing you
know you're seeing a lot of smart people
tell you what the most interests them
and most worries them on a daily basis
and you know sending you articles and
and videos that you and that's that's
why that's why I can't break my
connection to it because I'm following
so many smart people who are curating
for me an information diet that I still
appreciate
um and then I you know occasionally put
my own stuff out there just so it's like
a kind of a marketing channel but I'm
doing much less in the weeds back and
forth with even public people who I
notice uh you know you know poke me on
on a given issue or whatever so some
does it not go do you not have a little
thought in your head when you go to
tackle these very contentious subjects
you know and you know that you're gonna
get push back you know that you're going
to get flat you know that you're going
to get Mr represented do you not think I
really shouldn't be doing this or what
goes through your mind before you go out
and you make your point
well again I I uh I think about it more
than I used to now I mean I used to I
used to do it very there was a basically
there was no friction in the system and
that just was like okay this is like
that that cartoon meme you know somebody
on the Internet is wrong about something
I was that guy on Twitter and
um
so I'm not that guy anymore and I really
do pick my moments and
there's a cost to that because there's
you know that you're you decide to sit
certain moments you know cultural
moments at you sit on the sidelines and
um
but
I mean if I guess if I could just
distill it to a to a lesson here it's
like you're not
you don't you don't always need to have
an opinion about everything right you
certainly don't always need to have a
strong opinion about everything and even
if you do have a strong opinion you
don't always have to be the person
expressing that opinion because very
likely someone else will right and
you know given you know given those
adjustments to the to the machine you
you can
just decide you know is this do I really
want to spend the next
24 hours dealing with the aftermath of
this thing that I'm tempted to tweet
right or to say in some other format and
in particular it it relates to
the likelihood that certain
personalities are going to go berserk
and then with certain people it's it's
you know it's guaranteed that they're
going to go berserk so like do I yeah
here's this
this this odious uh opinion expressed by
a you know a semi-odius person who
really deserves to hear what I think
right now is it worth you know whacking
that Hornet's Nest and then just dealing
with dealing with and being seen to deal
with or to or to not deal with and to
maybe look like you can't deal with the
aftermath